a protest for votes members of a large
labor union out to encourage fellow
black Americans to get out and vote in
Tuesday's Democratic primary election in
Michigan many did not vote in the last
presidential election that was won by
Donald Trump I don't know people that
did not get our vote not sexy well you
do not do what you supposed to do this
is what happens in 2016
black voter turnout was barely fifty
percent the lowest in decades
Trump thus won several states with
sizeable black populations by the
slimmest of margins like Michigan this
ballpark is home to the Detroit Tigers
major league baseball team just for some
perspective in the last election just
here in the state of Michigan four and a
half million people voted this ballpark
seats 40,000 people and Donald Trump
beat Hillary Clinton by only ten
thousand votes while you look in the
state of Michigan black voters have them
feel they haven't felt that their votes
are important they've thought their
votes were taken for granted when you
look at the last presidential election
there were not resources spent here in
Michigan signs of decay in Detroit just
outside the windows where a group of
young activists are getting last-minute
instructions before door knocking for
votes
how important is african-american
turnout in the next election it's very
important in 2016 it was a very very
very close race between Trump and
Hillary if we could you know make an
impact by talking to these voters in
getting them to understand how important
it is to come turn out to vote whether
Biden or Bernie you know we can really
swing this state are you taking people
to the polls you are and he plans to
keep knocking on doors making sure of it
have a good one I'll leave this with
Gabriel Ando aljazeera Detroit